yeah i
um from an artificial intelligence
perspective
uh have a sense that there is
like a deep loneliness in the world that
all of us are really lonely like we
don't even acknowledge it even people in
happy relationships
it feels like there's like an iceberg of
loneliness in all of us
like seeking to be understood like
deeply understood
understanding us like having somebody
with whom you can have a deep
interaction
enough to where you can they can help
you to understand yourself
and they also understand you like i have
a sense that artificial intelligence
systems can
provide that as well but humans i think
crave that from other humans
in in ways that we perhaps don't
acknowledge and i i have a hope that
technology will enable that more and
more like clubhouse is an example that
allows that
are touring bots going to out compete
clubhouse like why not pro
sort of program your own session you'll
just talk into your
device and say here's the kind of
conversation i want
and it will create the characters for
you and it may not be as good as elon
and vladimir putin
but he'll be better than ordinary club
has yeah and one of the things
that's missing it's not just
conversation it's
it's memory so long-term memories what
current ai systems don't have
is sharing an experience together forget
the words
it's like sharing the highs and the lows
of life
together and the systems around us
remembering that
remembering we've been through that like
that's the thing that creates really
close relationships
is going through some [ __ ] like go
struggle
if you've survived together there's
something really difficult
that bonds you with other humans and
this is related to immigration in the
american dream
in what way people who have come to this
country however
weird and different they may be they are
their ancestors at some point probably
have shared this thing
right u.s is not going to split up it
may get more screwed up as a country
but texas and california are not going
to break off yeah i mean they're big
enough where they could do
it but it's just never going to happen
we've been through too much together
yeah ah that's a hopeful message
you